you
last time we saw how romance verbs used
different endings to point out the
person performing the action they also
have one of four thematic vowels inside
the ending depending on the verbs
conjugation
up to now we've only taken one slice of
time the present can toss or cantamos
are in the present tense tense is just
an old French word that means time
consider another time another tense the
past tense Latin verbs had a longer set
of endings in the past a mas for you
love but a maui ste for you loved
similarly a month versus a Maui don't
but vulgar latin shortened these endings
a musty Amaru
so Portuguese speakers say a master and
a motto an Italian has a mass tiene
model this tense gets called by other
names preterite historic past simple
past remote past in France Italy and
Switzerland romance speakers use a
different way of talking about the past
at least in everyday language they say
the equivalent of you have sung for you
saying so we hear to Ashanti
I can't Otto Diaz tanta oz condado
they're important but let's revisit
these constructions later we learned six
forms of the verb in the present
canta canta canta canta moose camp at
ease content there are six more forms in
the past can't I can't a ste campout
cantamos can't a STIs can't ah don't
stay in the past tense for a moment but
inject the concept of aspect aspect is
how or how often a verb is done it's a
simple distinction in romance one-time
completed verbs versus continuous
ongoing actions
the difference between them becomes an
issue in the past can't I can't Asti and
other past forms are simple pinpoint
one-time actions there's another set of
endings for continuous actions in the
past like junta bus you used to sing or
you were singing this is called the
imperfect and that bee is a good clue
you're looking at a vulgar latin
imperfect v-day bus fini bus many modern
languages do lose that be at least in
certain conjugations
there's one more tense the future tense
Western Romance languages developed
future endings by tacking the vulgar
latin word for have to the backs of
infinitives cantatas
Sardinian romance Romanian and southern
Italian languages didn't develop these
future endings they didn't share in this
innovation nor did they inherit the
classical Latin future instead they have
phrases for the future as a cantata
Vaikunta past present future three
tenses you now have a basis for
understanding how these three tenses
work in romance as well as the
difference between the preterite and the
imperfect in the past